and the Jason Dickinson line starts this game
against the top line of forwards for Anaheim
centered by second overall pick Leo Carlson the D
controls and it's poked out by Ryan stro now Troy
Terry Troy Terry shoots save Peter morazzi flip
to Ilia lbushkin there's a drop stick right off
the crease for Peter morazzi now pav mov knocked
away off that stick Murphy and kinsky pair now
defensively that's struck by Brett Leon and
whacked out to Center by Peter moric and Cole
Gutman a two-on-one Gutman save Gibson Tyler
Johnson and just trying to keep this game going
nor Leo
Carlson Carlson a shot rebound Alex color and
a open net that lbushkin couldn't find Carlson
another save by morazzi Peter morazzi he's had
two shots and they've both been 10 Bell saves make
that a third right there on the rebound I don't
know if murf got a piece of that but the Hawks
a little bit late in their slides that gives a
great a look up front and then Peter morazzi gets
from right to left in his crease for the rebound
makes himself big comes out Nikita zitz an whistle
Taps it to Center Ryan denado swoops in on the
puck Donado backand and that is dostall with the
save W jackob silverberg with kinsky in
front that finds the glove of Peter morzu
lbushkin has his pocket pick Joey Anderson
up to Murphy Dickinson Murphy kicked Away by
doal Sam
Carrick harzic sweeps the puck stopped by Conor
Murphy and now swept to vrono 20 seconds on the
man Advantage for Anaheim vrono a drive save
moric no rebound and Conor Murphy topples
waning seconds of the Anaheim power play Troy
Terry on the right side that was tipped by
mazic and the puck taken by gutus Brett Leon
over to Frank patrono vrono for Leon morazzi
a big stop and Conor vard the other way if it
not for him the Ducks could very well have two
goals the Hawks get caught in transition you
can see Lucas reel playing up with mobiler and
Bard there's a miscommunication and Lon just
slips right up the middle on an odd man rush
for a great redirection drives one behind the net
long rebound silverberg runs into Seth Jones and
Gutman takes the puck at Center Taylor radish
wins the puck battle radish kicked Away by Dall
Donado up to Conor Murphy and it's intercepted
by Alex color left off for Leo Carlson Carlson
shoots into the glove of morazzi Anderson to
Dickinson and classic sends it to Crevier down
low for Felino Felino looking for a man in front
flipped to the crease off the backhand and Dall
covers it up who's another rookie drafted one
year earlier than Bard 10th overall in 2022
that would be Kevin pinsky's draft class kurf
saved by doal boiler fires Rebound in the slot
picked up by Henrik couple of great chances
for the Hawks as Bo Gro Taps it for Tristan
luno Carlson to Center Terry shoots save morazzi
high pop up on the rebound that's a penalty Peter
morazzi heads off the ice extra attacker on
it's Conor Bard Bard back to Crevier Bard
a one time loose punck save do stall Tyler
Johnson had a good look at the rebound back
to Bard Jones Kev Jones to the net knocked
away Bard backhanded for Johnson around to
Kev Johnson just off the crease Jones feeds it
for him high loose pck and Dall flops on top
of it but I do love Christmas what say Bard Seth
Jones Bard toward the net Bard shoots kick save
made and Kev open has the puck radish Jones Bard
one timer soaked up by doall moiler looking for
a seat looking for reel too much on the Pu hus
out of the box Felino down low on a feat from
pinski Crevier tipped away blassic jumps
down an whistle Dickinson pinballs behind the
net bouncing Puck Leo Carlson runs into his own
teammate Tristan luno Anderson saved do stall
rebound Anderson in the wraparound tonight as well
and then he goes for the wraparound right after
Nick feno's driving to the net look pinski boiler
looking for his first point as a Blackhawk Kino
Gutman has his stick down Gutman backhanded
saved Dall and Felino sends it to Reichel
Felino boiler Kinski boiler pass handcuffed
him and it's Brett Leon with Sam Carrick to
his left Leon a drag and a shot blocked
by Kinski boil grabs the puck heads over
the line Tyler Johnson is there on the
other side Conor Bard he's open and KF
scores a bobbling puck for Bard so he passed
it up and the Hawks have a power play goal to
take the the lead oh what a play across to
kers have a backhand pass vrono gets caught
sleeping a little bit on Conor Bard love
the reaction from Bard here too he baits
vrono in and he doesn't realize how much space
he gives up there for KF for the onetime power
play goal for the Blackhawks Hawks capitalized
with a power play goal Fowler hit by an whistle
Puck thrown to patrono onto the goal line for
Fowler The Stick of Leon and the weak side tap
in by stro was denied amazing neutr Zone to
deny a three on two but it's Peter mirazic
we've been talking about all night for a reason
unbelievable save right there on the back door
by stro it's a rebound opportunity Leon kinsky
after the puck tap for boila Carrick turns and
fires off the Stick of moric and Leon robbed
by morazzi Fowler blocked by blasic on a would
be centering pass radish chipped over the line
Carlson has it way up to vrono and look out vrono
kicked Away by mazic and out of play less than
a minute to go and give up a partial Breakaway
here to vrono easily blocker away here by
Peter mazic he makes it look easy leushin
radish taken down silverberg what a
stop by morazzi vrono Kev vrono with
five mov runs out of time and Peter mazic
has his first shut out as a Blackhawk